let's go back to coding the content
provider the first of the required
content provider methods we're going to
implement is get type get type is used
to return the my meso seated with the
data at the given URI we use the URI
matcher we built earlier to match the
given URI against the expressions we've
compiled in for each match we return a
unique mime type that starts with either
VND Android cursor item for a single
record or VND Android cursor dur for
multiple items we've nicely already
defined these strings in our weather
contract in our tests for getting a type
we're going to compose your eyes using
the standard methods we have inside of
our weather contract then we're going to
pass these into our content provider
through the content resolver which is
how you call all functions in a content
provider and we're going to make sure it
matches what we have in the contract
I've placed the actual values as
comments so you can see really what's
going on note that some of these
returning type directory which means
they're going to return a list of
different items in their cursor while
others are returning type item which
means they will only return a single
item next we're going to have you finish
up get type you're going to add the
appropriate cases in the switch
statement but to return mime type to the
remaining URI types that we aren't yet
handling know there are only two to add
and they really look just like the ones
in weather contract